ein entsorgungshof in köln hier landet
was nicht mehr gebraucht wird oder
schlicht den geist aufgegeben hat
kühlschränke kabel computer fernseher
die verschiedenen elektrogeräte und
teile werden in zahlreichen containern
sortiert manches sieht äußerlich gar
nicht kaputt aus wir fragen nach warum
entsorgen die leute ihre geräte
haben sie versucht es zu reparieren ist
sie kaputt weil sie es tatsächlich
kaputt
mittlerweile ist es ein bisschen rum
weckwerth produkt geworden bei neue
kostet nicht viel und deswegen ist hier
also dann einfach mal weg
wie lange hatten sie den drucker jetzt
in benutzern ja denkt ich ungefähr der
aufwand ihn jetzt zu reparieren war uns
zu groß sein 9
bochum in nordrhein westfalen
hier besuchen virus biografie hallo
auch er hat ein kaputtes elektrogerät zu
hause der fernseher des 30 jährigen
lehrers macht kein sauberes bild mehr
[Musik]
man sieht einfach hier unten hat man so
einen ganz starken stich und wo ist das
einfach extrem schwarz dunkel ja
bildsignal ist aber ich kann damit
nichts anfangen
man kann ja nicht richtig erkennen wie
lange hat denn dieser fernseher jetzt
gehalten
ja das waren knapp zwei jahre und vier
monate und dann von heute auf morgen das
dann hat sie es probleme aufgetreten
kurz nach ende der zweijährigen
gewährleistung ein defekt für ross
wiener café ist das vor allem ein
finanzieller schaden
denn als vertretungslehrer in teilzeit
verdient er 1300 euro netto im monat
der fernseher hat neu immerhin rund 800
euro gekostet haben sie versucht das zu
reparieren oder reparieren zu lassen
ja ich habe eben bei zwei dienstleistern
angerufen hat er mir die haben gesagt
allein für die diagnose für die
fehlersuche wenn die 80 bis 120 euro von
mir verlangen
und die haben aber nicht gesagt falls
sie den fehler finden
wie teuer die reparatur ist und dachte
mir okay das ist so unsicher kann dann
sein dass die reparatur teurer als der
fernseher ist macht überhaupt keinen
sinn das zu reparieren ist russ
biografie mit seinem blauen fernsehbild
ein einzelfall
er recherchiert im netz ich bin nicht
der einzige der das problem hat
kurzlebiger spaß vor zwei jahren gekauft
hintergrundbeleuchtung schon defekt was
denken sie denn jetzt wenn sie diese
bewertungen lesen ja der dann ist bei
mir natürlich absolut klar dass das
irgendwie geplant war irgendwie dass es
nach der garantie kaputtgeht als ob er
so kaymer wäre nach zwei jahren ein paar
monaten kaputt aber bauen hersteller
ihre geräte wirklich so dass sie nach
kurzer zeit kaputt gehen in freiburg hat
man genau das erforscht am öko-institut
einer unabhängigen forschungseinrichtung
ist die bisher umfassendste studie zum
thema lebensdauer von produkten
entstanden sie das hat die forschungen
geleitet
gibt es eine sogenannte geplante ob so
lizenz die geplante ob solistisch gibt
es aber nicht im sinne einer design
manipulation sondern hinter jedem
produkt steckt eine produkt
entwicklungsstrategie das heißt die
hersteller planen auch die lebensdauer
der geräte
es gibt hersteller tatsächlich die die
geräte auch so konzipieren dass sie
nicht so lange genutzt werden wie es
technisch möglich wäre
hersteller planen also sehr wohl die
lebensdauer ihrer geräte dass sie
absichtlich bestimmte schwachstellen
einbauen lässt sich jedoch nicht
nachweisen warum denn so dass die geräte
so kurz nur halten also das ziel ist
kosten zu sparen damit man geräte auch
günstig anbieten kann
wir können davon ausgehen dass je
günstiger die geräte auf dem markt sind
umso höher ist auch die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass dort
qualitätseinbußen zu finden sind billige
materialien können also zu einer
kürzeren lebensdauer führen was die
forscher sicher wissen ist geräte werden
heute schneller ausgetauscht als früher
als unsere studie hat gezeigt dass die
nutzungsdauer von allen geräten in den
letzten jahren zurückgegangen ist und
wir müssen daran arbeiten dass die dass
diese zeiträume deutlich länger werden
als die es gerade sind was wäre die
optimale ökologische nutzungsdauer von
einem smartphone zum beispiel also es
gibt studien die das berechnet haben das
auch nur aus ökologischen und klima
gesichtspunkten ein smartphone zum
beispiel über 200 jahre genutzt werden
sollte und das ist natürlich jenseits
jeglicher realität die wir momentan
haben
das zeigt aber auch ganz deutlich wir
nachhaltig unsere lebensstile sind im
moment liegt die durchschnittliche
nutzungsdauer von smartphones gerade mal
bei zweieinhalb jahren bei
gefriergeräten ist die nutzungsdauer
innerhalb von nur acht jahren von 18,2
auf 15,5 jahre zurückgegangen
bei waschmaschinen von 12,7 auf 11,9 bei
notebooks von 5,4 auf 5,1 jahre
warum werden geräte immer kürzer genutzt
ist immer noch der hauptgrund für den
ersatz der geräte
das heißt 60 prozent der fälle wurden
geräte aufgrund eines defektes ersetzt
ob die qualität schlechter geworden ist
das wissen wir nicht was wir wissen ist
dass die geräte heute früh ersetzt
werden
das kann auch daran liegen dass früher
bei den defekten er repariert wurde
auch rosbach ii würde seinen defekten
fernseher gerne reparieren lassen
im repair café an der ruhr universität
bochum versucht man ihm zu helfen es
steht jedem offen der etwas zu
reparieren hat also die ist auf jeden
fall defekt und jetzt müssten wir
eigentlich mal schauen ob wir diese
ersatzteile irgendwo bekommen könnten
also es sind immer so einzelne led
stripes mit der seriennummer des led
stripes suchen die beiden im online shop
des geräteherstellers das ersatzteil
wenn wir nach suchen finden wir leider
gar nichts kein ersatzteil beim
zweitgrößten fernsehhersteller der welt
und das für ein problem das bei led tvs
nicht ungewöhnlich ist
warum gibt es das ersatzteil nicht im
shop das fragen wir bei lg nach
es folgt ein schriftwechsel der sich
über mehrere wochen hinziehen
drei wochen nach unserer ersten anfrage
heißt es das ersatzteil sei verfügbar
und können über den shop bestellt werden
wir schauen nach und finden wieder
nichts
wir wenden uns erneut an lg eine woche
später erhalten wir schließlich einen
link zum ersatzteil kostenpunkt knapp
200 euro fast ein viertel des neupreises
des fernsehers ein ersatzteil das schwer
zu finden und teuer ist nur ein
einzelfall in reutlingen besuchen wir
ein schwäbisches familienunternehmen das
sich ganz und gar der reparatur
verschrieben hat die bank gmbh detlef
lange und sohn steffen reparieren nicht
nur sondern sind auch organisatoren des
größten deutschen reparatur verbunds es
wird immer mehr an elektrogeräten
weggeworfen die elektro schrott berge
steigen kontinuierlich woran liegt das
ihrer erfahrung ja es gibt der meine
erfahrung nach zwei gründe das
eigentlich natürlich dass die geräte
immer günstiger werden und die zweite
geschichte ist bei früher ist ja ein
fernsehgerät auch kaputt gegangen nur da
sind wir zum kunden hin gefahren haben
repariert und dann also es hat halt eine
längere lebenserwartung gehabt in gänze
mit 23 reparaturen
heute ist es halt so wenn da die erste
reparatur eben kommt dann wird das oft
nicht mehr repariert und fliegt deswegen
raus warum dass es nicht mehr repariert
er zum einen weil der kunde oft gar
nicht glaubt dass man noch reparieren
kann oft gar niemanden mehr findet der
repariert und zum großen teil bekommen
wir von vielen herstellern gar keine
ersatzteile mehr und dadurch verhindert
man natürlich massiv die reparaturen wie
reparaturen verhindert werden will uns
steffen wangerooge anhand eines
prominenten beispiel zeigen der
thermomix die küchenmaschine die
angeblich alles kann und mit der
hersteller vorwerk jährlich den großteil
seines umsatzes macht neu kostet das
gerät zwischen 1000 und 2000 euro
angesichts dieses preises sind kunden
bei denen der thermomix nach einigen
jahren kaputt geht bereit ihn reparieren
zu lassen statt neu zu kaufen
mitarbeiter tomovic zeigt uns ein gerät
bei dem der schließmechanismus defekt
war
in ihrer werkstatt käme dieser fehler
häufiger vor meint er es ist tatsächlich
ein sehr häufiger fehler ist dieses
motor kaputt geht und das ist dann quasi
die verlegung nicht mehr oben zu fahren
kann und woher bekommen sie jetzt das
ersatzteil also das ersatzteil bekommen
wir tatsächlich nicht
in diesem fall haben wir dieses rätsel
mittels 3d drucktechnik nachgedruckt und
so kunden jedes kind retten
ein klitzekleines plastik zahnrad am
motor war das problem
es hat einen materialwert von ein paar
cent und kann doch die küchenmaschine
komplett außer gefecht setzen
beim hersteller bekommt die werkstatt
das ersatzteil nicht und warum bekommen
wiedervereinigt ja das müssen wir vorweg
fragen und würden sie uns keine
ersatzteile verkaufen möchten
interessant ist dass es also dieses
dieses dieser motor und entsprechend
auch diese zahnräder werden gar nicht
von vorwerk selber produziert sondern
von einem von den lieferanten im
schwarzwald und wir haben angefragt ob
wir das teil dort kaufen können ja
gesagt dass es leider nicht verkaufen
dürfen weil sie eben entsprechende
verträge haben die dänen das verbieten
wir fragen nach bei vorwerk warum
liefern sie keine ersatz oder
zubehörteile an freie werkstätten und
warum verbieten sie auch ihren
vertragspartnern dies zu tun
vorwerk schreibt uns dazu vorwerk ist
und war seit jeher ein
direktvertriebsunternehmen das seinen
kunden eine rundum betreuung aus einer
hand bietet unsere komplexen produkte
werden zentral in unserem
reparaturservice ausschließlich von
facharbeitern repariert
das ersatzteil verkauft vorwerk also
nicht der kunde kann das gerät aber bei
vorwerk reparieren lassen
kostenpunkt etwa 199 euro und fehlender
wettbewerb führt dazu dass reparaturen
oftmals teurer werden und somit
unattraktiv dieses problem hat auch die
eu erkannt
sie will ein recht auf reparatur
einführen ein erster schritt dahin sind
die neuerungen in der sogenannten
ökodesign-richtlinie damit treten ab
märz erstmals auch für deutschland
verbindliche regeln zur förderung von
reparatur in kraft
hersteller dürfen dann haushaltsgeräte
wie wasch- und spülmaschinen kühlgeräte
und displays nur noch auf den markt
bringen wenn sie ersatzteile und
reparaturanleitungen für sieben bis zehn
jahre zur verfügung stellen
außerdem soll die reparatur mit
herkömmlichen werkzeugen möglich sein
kleingeräte wie küchenmaschinen
zahnbürsten töne oder handys sind bisher
jedoch nicht von der regelung betroffen
in berlin treffen wir jemanden dem diese
neuerungen nicht weit genug gehen katrin
meier vom runden tisch reparatur ein
dachverband zahlreicher reparatur
initiativen und werkstätten gut ist auf
jeden fall dass eine ganz klare
produktstandards dann für den ganzen eu
markt haben und diese öko design
vorgaben müssen auf jeden fall auch noch
auf andere produktgruppen ausgeweitet
werden bei welchen produktgruppen weil
das besonders richtig smartphones stehen
jetzt quasi ganz oben auf der liste
computer auf jeden fall auch notebooks
mir grundsätzlich eben diese ganzen
elektronikgeräte die in den letzten
jahren in unmengen quasi auf den markt
gekommen sind all diese produkte werden
von der richtlinie nicht berücksichtigt
genauso wie der preis von ersatzteilen
sie können also auch weiterhin teuer
verkauft werden so bleiben reparaturen
oft unattraktiv
ich muss selber entscheiden können was
ich mit meinem produkt tue wenn es
kaputt geht na ob ich es selber
reparieren möchte ob ich es von jemand
anderem reparieren lassen
denn gerade entscheidet eben der
hersteller dadurch dass die ersatzteile
nicht zur verfügung stellen oder nur
bestimmten lizenz werkstätten zur
verfügung stellen
wir sind noch einmal in reutlingen bei
der wange gmbh teure ersatzteile sind
gerade auch bei smartphones ein
bekanntes problem zu bezahlen hierfür
das display allein schon ungefähr 195
euro im einkauf wenn ich jetzt das
vergleiche mit den preisen die jetzt die
vertragswerkstatt von samsung bringt mit
219 euro für so ein gerät dann habe ich
danach 23 24 euro brutto daran verdient
dann lohnt sich das die arbeit
eigentlich nicht
verkauft also samsung die ersatzteile an
freie werkstätten teurer als an seine
eigenen vertragswerkstätten wir fragen
bei samsung nach die belieferung der
unabhängigen reparatur werkstätten mit
ersatzteilen erfolgt wegen des hohen
logistischen aufwands über
spezialisierte distribution
dienstleister einen einfluss auf deren
preisgestaltung nehmen wir nicht
samsung weist die verantwortung für hohe
preise von ersatzteilen von sich und
spielt den ball weiter an die zulieferer
bei der reparatur von apple geräten sind
dagegen nicht so sehr die ersatzteile
das problem beim aktuellen iphone 12
stoßen freie werkstätten auf eine
technische hürde die rein gar nichts mit
den bauteilen zu tun hat also das
problem bei dem iphone 12 ist dass ganz
viele komponenten höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht mehr tragbar sind haben jetzt aber
so den ersten experimenten schon
festgestellt dass hier zum beispiel die
batterie wenn sie ausgetauscht wird ein
software fehler bringt wir fragen bei
apple nach warum sie eine software
blockade eingebaut haben die auch beim
einbau von originalteilen anschlägt doch
wir halten nur einen hinweis zu einer
pressemitteilung zu ihrem programm für
unabhängige reparatur anbieter dass
apple ins leben gerufen hat so sollen
unabhängige werkstätten ganz einfach
apple originalteile bekommen und damit
reparaturen durchführen können
der wertvollste konzern der welt hat
sich also auf die fahne geschrieben mehr
reparaturmöglichkeiten zu schaffen
stephen wroe hat sich mit seiner
werkstatt für das programm von apple
geworden
und wurden sie da jetzt angenommen wir
wurden abgelehnt obwohl wir meines
erachtens nach eigentlich alle kriterien
die apple dort stellt soweit erfüllen
wir reparieren seit 2011 ende 2011
smartphones wir waren eine der ersten
smartphone abhängigen werkstätten in
deutschland die diese reparaturen
angeboten haben
wir sind ein meisterbetrieb während
einer handwerkskammer eingetragen nach
welchen kriterien wählt apple seine
bewerber aus auf unsere nachfragen
bekommen wir schriftlich keine konkrete
antwort telefonisch teilt uns apple
deutschland mit man werde sich die
bewerbung der wange gmbh noch einmal
anschauen
tatsächlich erhalten wir ein paar tage
später eine e mail von steffen lange
rohr in der es heißt apple wolle die
bewerbung der werkstatt noch einmal
prüfen die notwendigkeit von mehr
reparaturen scheinen hersteller wie
apple also erkannt zu haben wollen
diesen markt aber selbst bestimmen
an der hochschule pforzheim sieht man
diese entwicklung kritisch
ausschließlich über die unternehmen
gefahrenes netz an reparaturwerkstätten
hat natürlich die tendenz vielleicht
auch so etwas wie monopol preise zu
machen
es ist ganz wichtig solche
monopolstrukturen zu durchbrechen und
hierfür muss man aber einen
regelungsrahmen bieten in dem nach
bestimmten qualitätsanforderungen freie
reparateur jetzt tatsächlich den zugang
zu ersatzteilen und reparatur tools
bekommen
was könnte denn die politik auf
nationaler ebene tun
ich denke es ist nötig dass es
gesetzliche rahmenbedingungen gibt wie
wir sie bei der kfz industrie haben da
ist nämlich geregelt dass freie
werkstätten tatsächlich auch die tools
bekommen die sie brauchen und
ersatzteile zur ordentlichen konditionen
wie die vertragswerkstätten das sollte
man hier auch machen was beim auto geht
scheint bei elektrogeräten ein problem
weil hersteller reparaturen erschweren
wie wir herausgefunden haben
auch deswegen landen immer mehr geräte
auf dem müll
ich glaube tatsächlich in aller regel
sind die größten bestandteile von
reparaturkosten sind sicherlich die die
arbeitszeit des handwerkers die stunde
eines handwerkers kostet vermutlich mehr
als der anschaffungspreis die freien
reparatur mit denen wir gesprochen haben
sagen aber das ist ja nur so teuer weil
die ersatzteile zum teil uns so teuer
verkauft werden bis vorhalten die
entsprechenden ersatzteile kostet auch
wiederum geld und es ist wirklich etwas
was dann eingepreist werden muss es gibt
ja viele geräte geht an der akku kaputt
und ich kann noch nicht mal diesen akku
austauschen warum wird denn bei produkt
design nicht mehr auf solche dinge
geachtet die frage der
reparatur fähigkeit ist sicherlich eine
die auch stärker in die in das design
mit künftig berücksichtigt werden wird
allein auf die absicht der hersteller zu
vertrauen
das reicht laut professor tobias brücke
nicht er sieht den gesetzgeber in der
pflicht verbraucher bräuchten mehr
informationen über die geräte vor dem
kauf es gibt ja viele verbraucher die
sehr gerne jetzt nachhaltig kaufen
würden wenn sie denn wüssten was
nachhaltiger ist da steht aber auf den
produkt nicht drauf also ich denke dass
die angabe der lebensdauer bei vielen
produkten tatsächlich die käufer bewegen
wird längerlebigen produkte zu kaufen
was aber tut die bundesregierung damit
geräte länger halten und besser
repariert werden können
immerhin steht im koalitionsvertrag dass
hersteller langlebigkeit reparierbar
kite und wiederverwendbarkeit stärker
berücksichtigen müssten in berlin
treffen die ministerin svenja schulze
wer ist dann schuld daran dass das so
schleppend vorangeht
ja es gibt große widerstände eben auch
von den herstellern gerade aus dem
aktivere hier wir wollten schon länger
vorschreiben dass akkus zum beispiel
austauschbar sein müssen und haben sich
hier große konzerne massiv gegen gewehrt
dass sowas kommt aber wieso macht die
politik so wenig auf nationaler ebene
was reparierbar kite und langlebigkeit
von geräten angeht wir haben keinen
nationalen markt wir haben einen
europäischen markt unsere produkte
kommen nicht alle aus deutschland
sondern kommen aus ganz europa und
deswegen müssen wir es auch mit allen
gemeinsam regel dass auch auf nationaler
ebene sehr wohl mehr passieren kann
zeigt unser nachbarland frankreich
hier wurde im januar ein sogenannter der
reparatur index eingeführt
wir sind mit der frau zum interview
verabredet die an der durchsetzung
maßgeblich beteiligt war
ladies ja was der reparatur index
funktioniert so dass der verbraucher im
geschäft eine note bis zu zehn sehen
kann wenn ein produkt zehn punkte
bekommt dann bedeutet es dass es sehr
gut reparierbar ist null bedeutet sehr
schlecht ich kann dazu auch ein bild
zeigen hier sehen wir zum beispiel eine
grüne farbe wenn es eine gute note gibt
und auch eine rote farbe wenn die noten
schlecht ist eine gute note bekommt ein
produkt wenn der hersteller eine
reparatur anleitung veröffentlicht
eine noch bessere wenn ersatzteile
verfügbar und verhältnismäßig preiswert
sind
[Musik]
ich glaube dass der index sehr wichtig
ist weil er den verbrauchern viel mehr
transparenz bietet sie können so nicht
nur anhand des preises und der qualität
des produkts entscheiden sondern auch
anhand dessen ob das produkt repariert
fähig ist oder nicht
warum sind in deutschland scheinbar
keine strengeren gesetze möglich dem
land das in europa am meisten elektro
schrott verursacht
um die elektroschrott berge zu
reduzieren müssen unsere geräte dringend
langlebiger werden dazu braucht es auch
ein recht auf reparatur noch bestimmen
auf die hersteller
wie teuer ersatzteile sind und wer sie
bekommt reparaturen werden damit oft
unattraktiv oder sogar unmöglich
um das zu ändern braucht es
entsprechende gesetze
denn nur wenn wieder mehr repariert wird
landet am ende auch weniger auf dem müll
[Musik]